my people show per nike in nike in nine
ci ho pensato come si dice non vorrei
allora siamo buongiorno agazzi però
tutti è quello che devo dire l'inizio di
vino siamo islanda
siamo in un horror ci sono delle pagine
sugli alberi e salendo per avete
consigliato un sacco sotto gli ultimi
horror calore che ho fatto e ho detto
che proviamo lo vedo sempre che comunque
salve vendo che sta grafica da
playstation 1 comunque sta andando
io non riesco a capire perché è
diventata la moda del momento farei
giochi con la grafica 21 che non che mi
dia fastidio è però mi fa strano perché
il nome avrebbero successo uguale si
giochi anche senza st gr comunque c'è un
obiettivo in tutto questo vado in giro
per la foresta a cup perché non mi hai
detto niente per tutto a 22 ottobre 1999
e fin qua
fin qua ci sono arrivato anch'io però
cosa succede
mi andro mi sono scaricato nelle mutande
insieme al regno gigante in no no la
torcia di sta spegnendo la posta foto
cosa devo fare effettivamente huston al
dg c'è una foresta enorme
cioè tu spiegami come faccio a sapere
comandare sono melo dg non hai idea
come faccio a sapere parlami c'era una
capanna all'inizio non so non ho idea di
dove sia andato
la direzione cofano sono anche tu non
saprei neanche tornare indietro in
datemi una mano
sentendo dei rumori che non mi piace
ah ok
sagittario un ragazzetto voci cesta
pietra a delle voci che ho sentito che
schiacci cracker di qua e inutile che mi
prendi per il no perché ragazzi qua
adesso va bene tutto
ehi ma dove vai sto andando a cercarmi i
problemi perché non è successo niente
quindi effettivamente è meglio se
succede qualcosa sennò un video piatto
però effettivamente so che questo gioco
saprà sorprendervi soprattutto dopo che
una roccia iniziato a parlare se vuoi il
suono dei crackers maciullati ragazzi e
poi l'ho amato lama donano ragazzi
serietà non ore incredibile dal fiero
una cagata
se ho sentito alcun urlare una donna
attenzione e qualcuno che appena
schiacciato vuvuzela molto forte e sta
continuando a farlo mio dio ragazzi sta
a casa orribile somiglia un sacco blair
witch sto gioco solo in versione ps 1
non so se avete visto voi ruiz come film
ragazzi non guardatela una merce la
porta c'è una mano sinistra inquinata
vicino alla porta
controlliamo che non ci sia nessuno
perfetto permesso non vorrei irrompere
nella vostra splendida dimora ma ho
visto gente in questa foresta e roccia
che parlano questo mi sembra il posto
più tranquillo di tutti quelli che ho
visitato finora permesso a camerino che
c'è anche il passaggio per il cane prima
che ci hanno messo un asse di legno
sopra non serve quindi noi questo non si
apre questa si apre invece salve è il
lato visto allora la smettiamo questi
vestiti bianchi che ma come ti permetti
non c'è neanche un come fai a respirare
che comunque fa caldo e in sto periodo
io non la metterei una roba di sei pazzo
lei e mi scusi ma per caso papa c'è un
altro c'è un tizio li guardi che poi un
casino se si becca un jump schera io
glielo dico a c'è una testa di minchia
che è successo allora io una domanda per
voi ce l'avrei ho ascoltate c'è gente ce
n'è uno anche quando so se l'avete visto
la domanda è perché schiacciati cracker
tutti amici finché non ti ruba la bce la
merenda
direi che il piano si spreca porca [ __ ]
di successo ma che ho
va bene ho fatto amicizia con un sacco
di gente di fuori vediamo se si può
uscire perché ovviamente di st guarente
non c'è proprio più voglia uscire a
parte che siamo in un'altra stanza basta
ragazzi quanti hanno circondato ok ok ok
ok ok la prima volta ragazzi piano è
piano con gli infarti che qualcosina chi
è che ha acceso le cambiero che dovete
risparmiare ma non fate i taccagni sulla
luce ecco scherzavo capricorno non lo so
ho sparato
ragazzi siamo di obici non a pietra che
parla e io non sono pazzo no come non
detto sono tornati in casa quindi sono
palazzo scusatemi ma questo è un
problema è perché non so dove sto
andando non capite le trasportano a caso
c'era una roba lì dentro non voglio
saperne ha visto anche a lei
io l'ho visto e l'ho visto che stava qua
e là e di sopra e di andato di sopra
vabbè vado di sopra prima crociera board
di sbattere le porte tutto sto bordello
è cessata la inside non mi interessa
entrare lì dentro entriamo di qua si è
spento tutto possono entrare qui perché
non vedo un cazzo fantastico permesso
è una preghiera per il sagittario la
smettiamo di invocare lo zodiaco le
candele in questa posizione vanno
ovviamente a formare una stella che è un
rito satanico però facciamo finta di
niente tanto non si parlava certo di
dell'età b questo gioco anche prima
c'è un tipo che sia appena arrampicato e
non è pietro ragazzi mezzo c'è uno che
sul tetto però io non vado sul tetto
vado qua salve a posto vincere non sto
capendo più niente ma credo che non sia
un gioco religioso credo è poi non so
stella di satana e siamo arrivati in
cima madonna santa di dio ma che è
successo ma di cosa stiamo parlando ma
che posso uscire o c'e quella fare nel
tetto che mi prende mi fa fuori cos'è
posso tornare giù faccio esco no no no
no no no no no no no no ma via
c'è qualcosa sotto
che brutto madonna questa sti cazzo di
cracker a questa ragazzi hanno fatto
benissimo l'anno fatta benissimo
l'ansia l'hanno fatta crescere in una
maniera pazzesca questa parte è stata
fatta beni che gioco pazzesco giuro da
chi era
no però non si sbattono le porte so bene
tutto
ci sono un po di segni sul pavimento e
non so cosa ma tanto non è casa mia
cazzi vostri
anche fuori da casa vedo io se posso
uscire alla finestra che mi sembra più
pratico basta sti cracker basta basta
per stare i cracker
io sento una donna ma ragazza ma sentite
voi non solo pazzo sento una donna che
urla
si può uscire da questo posto di merda
come si esce non si esce
fate vobis perché a posso andare i soldi
sotto proprio il posto in cui stia
attento perché c'è un tizio che si
arrampica io glielo dico comunque
qualcuno e corso di sotto prima io non
vorrei dover tregua dentro però non c'è
nessuno ok salve
no no no no no no no no non si apre
porca vacca sono chiuso di sotto c'è un
altro segno nello zodiaco che urla
smettiamo di urlare ma questo è stato mi
scusi c'era un pelato lì non ho fatto
niente
giorno io non volevo entrare qua e mi
hanno costretto a farlo video cioè io
org a [ __ ] che ero talmente in faccia a
sto tizio che non è affatto man 2
[Applauso]
a ero io quello pelato su nell'angolo
salve gli illuminati ecco tanto ci
mancava avevo detto che l'amazzone
quello l'avevo detto io si vedeva che
comunque c'era qualcosa di ragazzi lo
slider mense un mio vecchio amico mi
conosci non mi rompere le palle ti ho
fatto diventare famoso io praticamente
sei molto più brutto di questo ricordate
[Musica]
comunque secondo me un po di roba bella
fumate come ai suoi ragazzi se il video
è piaciuto al documento è un bel mi
piace anche i vari social che come video
fatte nella descrizione se non sento con
i siti iscrivetevi e dragoni sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video di rocce
che parlano illuminati renderman che
escono dai da dal simbolo illuminati
bene beh ragazzi
[Musica]